[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ihr seid wahrscheinlich
auf der suche nach einem party büfett
und da seid ihr bei mir genau richtig
denn ich habe hier ein rafael okotie ist
es her und da bekommt jeder gast sein
eigenes schälchen und das sieht nicht
nur super elegant aus sondern ist auch
noch sehr einfach und unkompliziert
nachzumachen
für die kokons dessert creme benötigen
wir 850 liter milch 30 gramm mehl 20
gramm speisestärke 80 gramm weizen gries
90 gramm kokosraspeln 120 gramm
puderzucker und 80 gramm butter aus den
ersten vier genannten zutaten kochen wir
uns jetzt einen einfachen grießbrei und
dafür gebe ich jetzt in mein kochtopf
die milch die speisestärke das mehl und
den weizen gries und ich verräters kam
zuerst mal klümpchen frei und las dem
herd an der stelle aber noch aus wenn
sich das ganze dann gut verbunden hat
schalte ich den herd ein und kochen das
ganze ein und zwar höre ich dabei
ständig damit das ganze am topfboden
nicht anbrennt und damit auch keine
klümpchen entstehen
sobald der grießbrei dann einmal
aufkocht seht ihr dass die masse schon
dicker wird an der stelle schalte ich
den hut auch schon wieder aus und dann
gehen wir die restlichen zutaten mit
hinein
zum süßen also den puderzucker mit
hinzugeben und anschließend auch die
kokosraspeln der puderzucker der schmerz
der in der hitze des krieges preis und
die kokosraspeln wir sind unverzichtbar
limitiert auf jeden fall mit rein tun
und wenn sich das ganze gut verbunden
hat dann gehen wir noch die butter mit
hinein und die schmilzt dann auch noch
in der rest hitze und verbindet sich
dann gut mit dem restlichen 3 und wem es
bis hierhin noch nicht aufgefallen ist
das ist exakt das rezept von meinen
schultern locker und das rezept verlinkt
ich euch mal in der infobox ist es auch
sehr lecker
das video ist zwar schon ein wenig älter
aber schaut euch gerne mal an
für die deko benötigen wir jetzt mal
raffaello kugeln und ein paar
kokosraspeln
die coco streams creme wird jetzt in
diese hübschen schälchen gefüllt und
zwar am besten noch warm damit es auch
nicht fest wir das besser spritzen
könnte ich habe selbst in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt das hat mir die
sache einfacher gemacht und zu den
schicken wollte ich euch noch was sagen
ich hab's solchen ehen vor box verlinkt
ihr bekommt 50 stück ich hab das rezept
so aufgeteilt dass ihr aus den genannten
zutaten 25 schälchen rausbekommt so
könnt ihr dann hoch und runter rechnen
und wenn ihr dann 50 braucht dann
verdoppelt einfach das rezept hier seht
ihr noch wie ich sie aus karriere also
einfach ein paar kokosraspeln verteilen
und die raffaello kugel ein wenig
reindrücken
die diese zahlen werden zwar als einweg
schalen deklariert aber ich hab sie hier
das zweite mal benutzt also nach der
partie nicht wegschmeißen sondern
einfach mit der hand einmal auswaschen
und dann könnte sie auch mehrmals
verwenden und die passende mini löffel
die habe ich euch auch noch mal in die
infobox verlinkt also wer interesse hat
schaut da auf jeden fall mal rein
und falls er das ganze jetzt in der
schoko variante nachmachen möchte dann
klickt hier auf das video das ist auch
nämlich 1 partyhit und ich habe dass
beides zusammen serviert das kam sehr
gut an und ich wünsche euch noch ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]